moving on to the midterms they are just
63 days away and president biden is
already back in campaign mode at events
in the swing states of wisconsin and
pennsylvania he touted the inflation
reduction act passed by democrats and he
continued a recent trend piling
criticism on trump supporters in the gop
for more on the president's messaging
nancy cordes is at the white house for
us nancy good morning
good morning tony the president isn't on
the ballot this november obviously but
his agenda will hit a wall if
republicans take back control of the
house or the senate so he is hitting the
campaign trail trying to fend off a fate
that befalls most first-term presidents
hello milwaukee
on labor day president biden hailed
labor workers who were key to his
victory nearly two years ago i wouldn't
be here without unions with the fall
election season now in full swing the
president is stumping for other
democrats and slamming former president
trump and his supporters the extreme
maga republicans in congress have chosen
to go backwards full of anger violence
hate and division republicans argue the
president isn't addressing the issue
voters care most about
it is inflation it's high record gas
prices and rising crime recent polling
finds that the president's approval
rating is up though he's still well
below 50 percent
in milwaukee monday the state's governor
campaigned with mr biden but wisconsin's
democratic senate candidate opted to go
to other labor day events send me to
washington d.c
outside pittsburgh pennsylvania's
lieutenant governor and senate hopeful
john fetterman stumped with president
biden for the first time since suffering
a stroke in may if i have to be in a
foxhole i want john fetterman in there
with me midterm elections during a
president's first term tend to favor the
party out of power especially in times
of economic uncertainty democrats hope
to buck that trend by capitalizing on
anger over rollbacks in abortion rights
in a new wall street journal poll voters
said the supreme court ruling
overturning roe v wade was motivating
them to cast their ballots even more
than inflation was it's become a
consistent theme in democratic ads
doug margiano is too extreme on abortion
this guy is so extreme way too extreme
for me
republicans have seen those same polls
some of them are softening the abortion
language in their campaign literature
others are simply trying to focus on
other issues but democrats are making
that tough to do president biden hitting
the campaign trail again going to the
battleground state of ohio on friday
vlad
all right nancy court is first at the
white house nancy thank you